we had a jungle of Tears I want to be
their wine gate and the turning tide of
Tammy is ridiculous this is your
bachelor season 24 episode 5 recap grab
your glasses it's time for roses and
rose say hi everybody i'm lauren zima
look at my two-step tea I made a shirt
that's ready for dancing ready for line
dancing and cowboy jammin because that's
what we're doing on this season of The
Bachelor just kidding all we did was cry
this episode let's get to it because we
have a lot to get to we have three hours
of television and I'm gonna say it right
off the top and plug it The Bachelor is
giving us a to count them one two step
episodes this week so we will have two
episodes of roses and rosy everybody
we're not gonna let you down they might
have been sobbing nonstop in this
three-hour Odyssey of an episode but
we're gonna keep you laughing okay we're
here for you so we will also put up an
episode of roses and rose a on Thursday
it's twice the rose a hope everyone
staying hydrated hydrated was with tears
look at all these notes I have and every
single page just is crying tears sobs
those are my notes Tammy don't say
anything about what I'm about to do
Tammy I'm just concerned for your
well-being don't judge my lifestyle
choices Tammy but I need a drink
I'm gonna keep smiling this whole time
because we need that you know cuz all
you guys dealt with was the mechana
faces so I'm just gonna keep on with the
wrinkles anyway remember we were left
with the to be continued well now we're
continuing on the Alea portion of our
evening saga and drink every time they
talk about Alea like she's not sitting
right there I don't think she's here for
Alicia with Peter I think it's for the
rose there like she said well I think
she she said Aleya hi you hi she made
her bed and she has two Alea in it and
after everything
Peter pulls Alea aside to ask her to go
home it's probably time to say goodbye
why so many first the first time someone
I think has been sent home and then
returned to get a rose and then the
quickest turnaround on her leaving again
drink for the whole time Alea was back
we're done that's it yep mm-hmm
it was an emotional episode so we're
already gonna get into the deep
emotional question of the week which is
how do you guys feel about Peter I gotta
try my best this is so hard this season
is feeling like such whiplash I feel one
way about one person one week it changes
by the next week last week I was loving
Peter this week I was starting to see
where the women were coming from the
women have been upset because they think
Peter is feeding into and rewarding
drama oh yeah you accept this rose I
felt frustrated with Peter just because
of his indecisiveness looking back I
actually think when Peter was talking to
Alea and Victoria P he should have sent
to both home write that in there he knew
they were both liars Leia had admitted
to asking Victoria P to lie about their
relationship he didn't
want us to not be able to be shared and
Victoria P had been caught hiding their
relationship I'm telling you that my
truth is the treatment all you've said
is that you want honesty out of all this
Peter how was it quick rant off the top
Tammy don't you look at me Tammy I wrote
down on one page drinking the note so
let me know how you felt about this
episode about Peter and a quick note of
positivity shoutout to McKenna's cute
barrette it got a lot of screen time and
I think I'm gonna get one little this
top black Rios in Bozeman farías
am I in kindergarten whatever okay I
just sent away home Aleya is gone and
Peter is doing some real boots on the
ground work to reassure the women he's
having good conversations I understand
your frustration telling them he cares
was thinking about you your live it up
and patching things I will do whatever
it takes to reassure them drink for
every good conversation I'm so sorry to
use every single one of them out there
that I hadn't put you guys through was
it bringing me back to their first name
this is working with you and I'm gonna
celebrate every moment of positivity
this episode then Chris Harrison showed
up but we still have to have a rose
ceremony and the drama is still there
Tammy is loosely threatening arson if I
don't get a rose tonight I'm going to
set the building on fire which is
interesting considering how much she
comes after Kelsey's mental stability
throughout the episode
you close your eyes Tammy Tammy you
close your eyes you go play a contact
sport or something okay playing my sport
no I think something everything that's
happening all this drama is making me
doubt myself McKenna is losing it at a
rose ceremony again I think we've done
it don't drink to this before but
seriously don't drink every time we kind
of loses it I think I don't want you
guys to think that I went in there and
McKenna's faces I mean somebody can be
like hey how are you and she's like I
just want very hard to be seen all we're
seeing is your barrette
but it's cute I wrote down we said
goodbye to Deandra Savannah and winger
II it was like a cute pajama linger he
said remember her name I don't say get
international and then a little more
positivity from Cleveland to Costa Rica
everybody I love this because we're
always uplifted by a colorful visual you
know what I mean
we got the jungle we've got a new sewer
arriving and Sydney still wants Peter to
learn her Italy I want him to just like
finally get to know me on a deeper level
and Kelly is just our normal Nancy she
says she's tired from traveling Costa
Rica seems cool but I'm pretty tired
from traveling has anyone ever not
belong to more than Kelly the lawyer
this is a weird process is a weird
journey do you think Kelly's invested in
this let me know in the comments below
so we've had tears we've had Joy's and
now we're getting violence it's the
debut of Peters much talked about cuts
[Music]
crazy crazy story he just kind of walked
in with it right I mean I was looking
forward to this episode in interviews
peter has told me there was so much
blood
it looks like a murder scene he was
really freaked out by the whole thing
but he just kind of comes on a bullet
hey guys yeah 22 stitch get Sydney ready
who's ready to step let me know if my
forehead is bleeding I was walking out
of the lobby yesterday the stitches
holding is this okay in the Sun the
Costa Rican sign I don't know about go
to the waterfall but anyway the story
okay and I ran into the golf game he
didn't have any footage of it they did
kind of a recreation and then at the
very end we saw this brief security
camera footage I'm assuming Peter was
with producers at this time - no one
without an iPhone yes he's bleeding yes
we're scared but I'm like get it on tape
this is the show I'm just saying there
were probably several of them couldn't
multiple people have been attending to
Peter and one person's like I'm gonna
film this horizontally and we can put it
on the show later how did you guys feel
about the explanation and recreation of
the cut incidence let me know in the
comments below and I just don't want our
night to get lost again a season of
whiplash last week I was complimenting
Kelsey and saying perhaps Kelsey for
Bachelorette this week Kelsey really
took a turn first she's explaining time
to us and how upsetting it is I love my
dates vivillon
that was last week and now we're on a
new week and
we're in a new place but a quick turn of
positivity and we're happy every time we
get one this episode little picnic
Sydney and Peter have a really nice
one-on-one what did you think of their
connection again tough to tell who
Peters frontrunners are because now he
seems so into Sydney and he gives her a
747 and tells her she's the best kisser
you know you're the best kisser shut up
Oh Peter loves an extreme you are the
best kisser oh I thought it was nice
they connected they were in a beautiful
place they had champagne back at the
Costa Rican version of the bachelor
mansion I wrote down the emotional toll
is beginning to show itself in Kelsie's
hair I'm not here to judge like your
face your but about how you present
yourself that ponytail was you know we
get another confessional from Kelly and
drink every time that Kelly's
confessionals are her writing a brief on
why she shouldn't actually be here no I
don't know what we're doing but I'm sure
it'll be fun
this is a weird process is a weird
journey I know he checks off a lot of
boxes but like am i into it you're
exactly what I needed after yesterday
with the whole head injury back to
Sydney and Peter she's been through some
stuff and Peter very sweetly says he
wants to be her rock this is very me so
much I can be your rock I want to be
that rock and then they get in the water
in their bikinis and Peter and true
Peter fashion puts her up on a rock
it is wild how this van can find a
counter I just look at you
but he's gonna put you up on something
you know if you like sir he's gonna put
you up on a pedestal kind of it's nice
by the way drink for every different
place they found to make out in that
little pool it was like an episode of
house hunters over here we've got the
corner and then oh there's a beautiful
amount of square footage because this is
the second bedroom and actually it's a
nice open living space between the
kitchen and the living room yeah who
doesn't love an open floor plan back at
the mansion I wrote down Kelsie's hair
is now collapsing as is her mental state
drinking for every nonsensical things
she's saying somebody's hitting other
people yeah but it is kind of fun for
show she doesn't seem aware of were able
to handle how the show works and then as
much as I've been liking Kelsey I really
didn't like what she had to say about
Sydney I like Sammy a lot I think she's
cool
but she's a traumatic
speaking of whiplash I like you you
[ __ ] what did you think of Kelsey's
commentary give me your own commentary
in the comments below today we're gonna
be shooting a photo shoot this was a
good group date we've had so much drama
on the group dates
this one was supportive they're doing a
photo shoot for cosmopolitan magazine's
it had like a good premise to it and a
sexy premise they're taking pictures
they're in the waterfall I mean I gotta
give them credit if someone gave me no
warning that I was about to pose in a
bikini for photos and Cosmopolitan
magazine
I'd be like is this some kind of high
collared shirt I can wear instead I'm
not ready so cheers to the ladies they
were very good sports and no one had
major meltdowns publicly at least Kelsey
was melting down on your head thorns are
better - I am struggling at all so
Victoria Evan Peter get on the cover me
comin at you with the day
had to talk about the Cosmo cover
Victoria F's past has become problematic
and Cosmo is not running that cover
anymore you can get detailed coverage up
at our website ET online comm also want
to tell you in e t--'s broadcast tonight
we are running an exclusive clip from
Wednesday's episode so do not miss it
right god and then every week Victoria F
says at least one thing that makes me
want to lift her up give her support and
confidence and kind of a life lesson
it was just her birthday and she says
quote 26 is depressing OD 26 Victoria
you are in the prime of your young life
you are on a reality show you just got
put on the cover of Cosmopolitan
magazine enjoy myself for a moment
expand I think that life gets better
with each year that you have on this
earth as long as you have your health
were you really looking for as we
continue to grow we continue to mature
to learn to experience other people in
other cultures and that helps us expand
as people I like myself more and more
with each passing moment in my life and
I'm just pursuing my goals and my dreams
and finding people that I connect with
more and more as I learn how to connect
with myself
additionally so I say continue and
celebrate each birthday in each year and
I just hope to be one day l deld
elder sitting on a porch drink and a
loved one my friends
be happy but Peter disagrees with me he
says I enjoy every second with Victoria
ethics enjoy every second I still miss
Victoria F and it's never enough well it
might have to be enough I don't know how
much longer she's gonna be happy you
know twenty sevens is on the horizon
don't drink for every 747 Peter then
tells Hannah and though that she's quote
the cutest thing ever the cutest thing
ever
so everybody's chatting with Peter and
it's going well they're talking true
feelings real connections are happening
reassurances are underway of feelings
and then Hannah tells Peter that she
believes Kelsey has a drinking problem
I've seen multiple times at people
drinking excessively tam Hannah
now I've even turned on Tam Hannah what
did you guys think of this what we know
about Peter is that he likes bold women
he likes women who come and talk to him
and he doesn't seem to have a problem
with the women discussing the other
ladies on the show because he wants to
know the truth about everything so I
think that was Tami's goal but accusing
someone of drinking excessively is
pretty big you know and it's not really
your judgment call to make I don't think
it's one thing to come to the lead and
say this person said X things like I
don't know why I shouldn't just tell
Peter what Kelsey said about Sydney it's
another thing to say I'm coming to tell
you the assessment I've made on someone
else's physical and mental well-being it
wasn't a breakdown but then Kelsey
doesn't do herself any favors because as
she's telling Peter that she didn't
break down she breaks down it didn't
have an emotional
I was fat I was really sad I've never
seen anything like this someone talking
about how okay they are walk rying like
I don't want to feel that that doesn't
mean I'm having an emotional breakdown
what do you guys think the difference is
I suppose what we're discussing here is
differentiating between sobbing and
going over the edge mentally emotionally
where's the edge of this waterfall oh
then she did say supposably Peter and I
just talked and supposedly I'm taking
back to champagne gate because when
Kelsey gets pushed she starts swearing
she gets a little mean and how did you
feel about Tammy not stepping up and
saying she was the one who spoke up to
Peter and if you say you got on a girl
who doesn't have fun when they're doing
like cool activities and positivity
again sort of Kelly gets the one-on-one
that was okay our thresholds getting
lower now isn't it the episode is going
on and the tears are happening and we're
just getting more and more appreciative
of any little moment of festivity yeah
Kelly's talking about the journey and
the process I felt like her inner
monologue was just this they go to a
shaman to learn about their relationship
our me and Peter on the same stage of
life and they asked the question is the
pendulum swinging in the right way for
their relationship in the shaman just
lays it on the line he says no Mona Lisa
get off he says and I quote the pendulum
says no pendulum says no that's honestly
right now I feel like I'm getting more
better I do not want to be someone
that's giving you know 75% compared to
25 we're swinging back and forth on this
show we don't know how to feel we might
need that shaman in here you know tell
us what's up tell us if Peters being too
indecisive made that call on Kelly and
then Peter keeps Kelly around pendulums
so again Peters being indecisive Lord
hmm so how did you get so drunk drink
for every conversation that calcium
Tammy have this episode so much talking
so much crying so little resolved you
can continue to cry and whittle your way
and bottles of wine I want to say whose
side are you on but again I feel they're
both wrong that's felt like a lot of
this season to me that there are lots of
conflicts happening with women where I
can't even make the choice and only
decisive like Peter what is this season
of The Bachelor doing to me I don't
think I am
I blame Peter Oh got him the women back
to the positive positive okay I've had
zero opportunity to progressive that's
not true I don't know but like I was
trying so Peter does show a moment of
strength he got a calls Kelly out says
you really need to know you need to be
here I need to know that you are on that
same level in that same page but I'm
learning that Peter is someone who if
you do give him that reassurance he'll
glom on to it and he gets tell you Lois
hey guys real quick one I wanted to
speak a little bit more on Kelly and
Peter's date I did think Kelly made her
points quite admirably she is a lawyer
and she's just very normal and grounded
Kelly for Bachelorette or is she too
normal and it wouldn't be insane enough
let me know
hey then Wow back to Peter's love for
bold women kelsey gives us our first
sneak off of the season and she goes to
peter's costarican mansion with a view
and tells him that since us being said
about her in the house it means going
around telling everybody that like she
thinks I'm a drinking problem
and then it turned into popping pills
and now we also learned people saying
that she has a pill-popping problem what
good lord
I mean look Kelsey did say mean stuff
and she's breaking down but can we give
her a break
I don't need a rose ceremony tonight to
know how I feel about you and then Wow
like Peter couldn't cement more how much
he loves a woman who comes to him and
assures him and tells him her feelings
he just gives Kelsey a rose in that
moment you just continue to reinforce to
me that you want this just as badly as I
do the first time that's ever happened
on the show has anyone ever gotten a
sneak off Rose before please let me know
in the comments below and this is like
the 47th time already 5 episodes into
this season but I've had to implore you
guys to please be bachelor historians
and let me know because we got a lot of
firsts what's stressful first thanks
it's great isn't it
I love when they give us first such
beautiful creative we don't know what's
gonna happen think if it keeps on giving
I love this show Peter also says to
Kelsey don't worry about the other
lady's opinions they don't matter don't
worry about the other girls Peter you
are the one loving it when women come to
you with opinions about the other women
okay
speaking of indecisive this one Tammy
okay hey here's to Kelsey coming back
from her sneak off moment in discussing
the women she wanted to be upfront
I'll explain she wanted to tell them I
got a rose I was not expecting this and
I don't want to hide it and it was so
get awkward she's like so this is really
awkward for me right now but I do want
to address to you I just wanted to tell
you guys they got this rose
and I see that you're all looking at me
like you want to kill me or perhaps put
another mental illness label on me but I
didn't mean for this to happen and so I
just hope it will be smooth sailing
[Music]
yeah you're excited to see Peter and get
into the cocktail party then we're going
to the cocktail party but I guess maybe
they feel like everyone's drinking too
much because there's not gonna be a
cocktail party we're going right to the
rose ceremony what we're going straight
to the rose ceremony tonight
all of the women blames Kelsey for this
did you think that was fair if I ain't
gone to talk time we could have had a
cocktail party I don't think it was
Kelsey's fault they cut the cocktail
party all the time guys has anyone seen
the show
just like we took a moment for McKenna's
Verret I do want to take a moment from
McKenna's newest face the tongue what
was she doing she's like and it was like
a windshield wiper back the other way
what's he doing oh that really got me
cranked tears of joy we needed it tears
of joy positive I'm so frustrated so at
this point in this three-hour tour of an
episode I started to lose it a little
bit just like Kelsey you know my hair is
coming out I'm crying just
a lots happening I just started writing
down so much fighting so much fighting
not your place to go telling that to
other people and if you don't know what
you're talking about so now where I'll
turn it on Tammy and everyone is crying
and the most consistent thing is all the
inconsistency
[Music]
we finally get to the rose ceremony and
then pour I think her name is Lexi I'm
glad you guys had your mini cocktail
party says wow we're just turning this
rose ceremony into the cocktail party
because drink every time someone leaves
standing at the rose ceremony to go talk
to Peter Peter I'm sorry before we begin
can I talk to you can I see you for a
second yeah they're probably thinking it
works for Kelsey and it did work for
Tammy and McKenna they both got roses
and it didn't work for Lexi she went
home so again Peter likes bold women
Lexi Lindsey God what's her name and
Cheyenne Cheyenne I'm not sure anyway
there's another episode of this
wonderful show that we all love so much
is the gift that keeps on giving and
it's given us more on Wednesday okay
love you guys so much please follow me
on Instagram or Twitter if you don't
already I don't usually pour wine at the
end of the episode but you know what
Tammy I'm gonna do it I want whatever I
want so I don't need you to tell me
Tammy okay if you want a personal
message for me I'm also available on
cameo and again we will have another new
episode of roses and Rose a on Thursday
is ridiculous you guys are super stable
okay nobody's breaking down nobody
breaking down we're all good just
emotions crying okay nobody's nobody's
drinking too much okay okay fine
proceed you're real good yeah JC you
feel stable
[Applause]
[Music]